what do you think politically were you
at their gotta yelled at the beginning
who you for but you just became white
that was the widest burner in the
beginning you were like hey I said how
you don't have sound like who you voted
for you like Bernie
I'm like oh you became a white person in
an hour that's amazing
you're a general contractor let's build
all the hat all thirteen houses for
ms-13
that's funny pussy's he likes it because
he's in the gang kids only can you yell
down as Trump says I love Hispanics yes
why'd you say I've worked more men than
you have you know probably probably but
we've done it all everybody's papers
[Applause]